Welcome back everyone, I had a chance to see The
Flash movie so this will be my review there's a
whole bunch of stuff to talk about so please don't
post spoilers in the comments till after the movie
comes out in theaters but if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I've got a bunch more videos planned for
when it does come out I will do a full breakdown
Easter eggs for the post-credits scene everything
else during the movie because there is a lot of
stuff that they cram into this movie it has to do
a lot of stuff for DC just in general the movie's
been through several iterations over the years
they've been trying to make a Flash movie since
the late 80s that's how long they've been trying
to get The Flash movie out originally Jeff lope
who mostly you'll know from Marvel television
like he did a lot of Marvel TV series for a
while as their President also wrote some of the
most famous Batman comics of all time too tried
his take on the flash back in the 80s but couldn't
crack the story so there was never an actor cast
for that but this is well before John Wesley
ship did The Flash TV show during the early
90s but right around the time that the studio
was doing Michael Keaton's Batman 1989 with Tim
Burton so very apropos the past several years all
through Zack Snyder building his version of the
Snyder verse like the Man of Steel movie Batman
v Superman his version of the Justice League The
Flash movie has had several different directors
and writers attempt to try and make it until
eventually they found Andy muschietti previously
he'd mostly been known for doing the it movies
the past several years acid passed through all
those different directors and writers the actual
movie and stuff like the actual story changed
several times until they landed on a version of
Flashpoint which is what you're seeing in theaters
now the movie itself is meant to be a version
of Flashpoint combined with Back to the Future
tropes in a soft reboot of the DC movies so that
James Gunn can recast any of the actors that he
wants to in the next several years and the funny
thing about that is that things changed even while
Andy muschietti was still finishing the film like
when he was hired on the studio had a completely
different 10-year plan for DC movies Henry Cavill
was still getting ready to make Man of Steel too
he was still going to be their version of Superman
for the next 10 years years but by the time he'd
finished filming The Flash movie and they were
almost finished editing it James Gunn was hired
which is also kind of funny because there are
some moments in the movie that referenced James
Gunn's other non-marvel movies just in general
Andy muschetti would have included some James
Gunn's Easter eggs before he knew that he was
going to be his boss shortly after they finished
filming the movie but the good news is even though
the movie went through so many different versions
along the years as they tried to make it so many
different directors so many different versions
of the story Andy muschetti actually did a
really good job so good in fact that James Gunn
just offered him the job to direct Batman brave
in the Bold your own Batman in a brave and bull
Direction what would you want to put on what kind
of spin would you want to put on that character
oh that's uh I don't think I can talk to that yeah
one of the best thing things he does in the
movie is the way he treats the different
versions of Batman like his versions of Batman
are so good that's one of the reasons why he's
probably going to be hired to do Batman brave in
The Bold and even though all the trailers do make
the movie seem like it's a Batman movie with the
Flash in it just because there's so much Batman
stuff going on with Michael Keaton's version of
Batman coming back and Ben Affleck's version of
Batman the trailers are a little misleading in
that most of the movie does follow and is about
Ezra Miller's version of The Flash but obviously
the other interesting thing is that he's playing
multiple roles like he plays a couple different
versions of Barry during the movie the movie
just in general is also meant to be sort of a love
letter going off sending off point for the Snyder
verse of movies they're not completely retconning
or getting rid of the Snyder versus movies in this
because we're talking about Flashpoint here the
whole idea of different timelines the Multiverse
they use the movie to canonize many different
previous DC movies even the non-snider burst
movies to the larger Multiverse the same way that
Marvel has been doing that in its recent movies
too very apropos we just got Spider-Man across
the spider-verse they're kind of doing the same
thing in that movie too because it's coming from
Sony and Marvel not just marvel themselves lots
of Multiverse going around in the big comic
book movies all over the place if you are a
big fan of Batman though you will love this movie
if you like Ben Affleck's Batman if you're a huge
fan of Michael Keaton's Batman back in the day
seeing him come back probably one of the best
parts of the movie for instance Ben Affleck said
that this is probably the best version of Batman
that at least he feels like he's ever done in any
of his DC movies including all the Zack Snyder DC
movies not that Andy muschetti did a much better
job with Ben Affleck's Batman than say Zack Snyder
did just that the brief material the brief
scenes that Ben Affleck had in the movie were
really really good and it's my best [__] I've
done I finally figured out how to play the guy
no really I got it for real I was like hold on am
I is that I quit I know I quit and I know I came
back to you but I got it now and uh it helps you
see the character and now you want another chance
to play it I was like wait a minute I got it am
I still wait can I guys are we still rolling can
we write another story am I when he jokes about
wanting to come back all of a sudden now like I
know I said I was gone but I want to come back
that's how good he comes off in this movie now
he's only in a small part of the movie but it is
a really good send-off for his character cannot
say enough about Michael Keaton's Batman 2. not
only is he's just a great actor most of you of a
certain age like Beyond I say like the age of like
30 or so probably remember Michael Keaton's Batman
he probably winds up being your first Batman for
the most part one of my earliest memories of comic
book movies is sneaking into Batman 1989 in the
theater without really understanding what I was
sticking into not knowing that it was going to be
that original Batman movie when I was a little kid
no joke I was in the mall in the movie theater
when people still went to malls to watch movies
snuck into the movie theater right as he was
getting ready for that you want to get nuts seen
do you want to get nuts foreign we're talking
about breaking records here bringing people
back who play characters from a long time ago
he actually just broke the record for Patrick
Stewart's Professor X and Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
for the length of time an actor has portrayed a
character so he is now the current record holder
but also Hugh Jackman and Patrick Stewart both
coming back in Deadpool 3 so like they are
continuing as well too with their characters
and even though they do include a lot of those
nostalgic moments from Michael Keaton's Batman
in the trailer of those iconic lines the movie
doesn't completely rest on Nostalgia when you go
to his character he actually does a really great
job is an evolution of his version of Batman like
it's meant to be a continuation of where he left
off and Batman Returns generally the movie treats
Val Kilmer's version of Batman Batman Forever and
George Clooney's Batman in Batman and Robin as
completely different versions of the character so
if you saw his Batman movies back in the day and
you wondered what happened to his character after
the events of Batman Returns they do get into that
during the movie they introduce Sasha Kanye as the
new version of Supergirl she's meant to be sort
of like the cousin of Henry cavill's version of
Superman but from a different timeline where she
wound up landing on planet Earth she did a great
job as the character I really do hope that they
bring her back when they do the woman of Tomorrow
movie like they do have a Supergirl movie planned
under James Gunn's new plan but they haven't
announced who that Supergirl is going to be it's
not going to be Melissa from the DCTV universe
so it'll either wind up being Sasha's version of
Supergirl or somebody completely different that's
how fresh all of James Gunn's plans for the next
10 years are but he seemed like he loved the Flash
movie so much and she's so good during The Flash
movie like she will be one of the highlights of
the film for most people I would not be surprised
if a version of her character comes back in some
way in the future either in Flash sequels if they
wind up doing those or in the Supergirl movie
most of her storyline in the film is based on
the original Flashpoint story with some big twists
they try to be relatively faithful to some of the
big beats of Flashpoint but they don't do the
literal flash point story like they did in the
Justice League flash play movie which was a much
more literal adaptation of that comic book story
or for instance The Flash TV show's version of
Flashpoint because they did pretty much the same
story a couple years ago there will be a lot of
comparisons between the different versions of The
Flash and they did cross over in the crisis
on infinite Earth on DC TV so the TV shows
have already been doing this job of canonizing
everything together from all over the place all
of these different movies not just the Zack Snyder
line of movies I don't want to get too much into
grant gustin's version of flash there'll be a lot
of comparisons to him but a lot of people are just
wondering what's going on with the future of all
these different DC projects because of the reboot
so I don't want to talk too much about what's
going on in the movie because it does kind of get
into spoilers Michael Shannon comes back as odd
from the Man of Steel movie he was great in that
movie even though it was a very different take
on the character he's playing the same version
of the character just in a slightly different
timeline so there are some subtle variations the
interesting thing though is he said that when they
called him to come back he said that he actually
he talked to Zack Snyder about coming back first
and got his Blessing like Zack Snyder is generally
happy with the movie recently Sasha Kanye even
said that she was at a screening with Henry
Cavill who saw the movie and gave his Blessing as
well to her version of Supergirl so it is nice to
hear that they've moved past a lot of the drama
behind the scenes with DC movies just in general
because it got really crazy there for a couple
years that being said James Gunn didn't really
have any creative force in the movie like he
wasn't hired till after they'd finished filming
the movie there were some minor edits to the
ending just to help set things up for his new
10 years of DC movies just like a couple minor
tweaks but for the most part the movie is the
version that they meant to make before James Gunn
was hired they have been posting a lot of the new
music from The Flash movie and even though I am
still partial to the flash theme from The Flash
TV show a lot of the new music for the movie is
really really good for the most part I did feel
like the movie was a good send-off to the Snyder
versus move it's like a good swan song with that
completely erasing everything or like completely
getting rid of the Snyder versus movies like they
do leave things in a way that will allow everybody
that they want to bring back to come back in the
future should they want to bring them back but
the movie does have a clear beginning middle
and end so if they do want to recast Ezra Miller
in the future they can do that and it will make
sense the interesting thing though is that before
the writers strike they did commission and finish
a draft for the flash too like there is a sequel
movie that they have written based on the first
movie if they do want to make it but it hasn't
been greenlit yet that's how happy the studio
is with the way the movie turned out I think it's
just a question of how much fans will like the way
the movie turned out do stay through the credits
there is a post-credits scene of course I'll do
a full breakdown Easter eggs for the entire movie
for all the post-credits scenes once it does come
out in theaters there is a ton of stuff a ton
of Easter eggs that they cram into this like
I said it is a love letter to a lot of those
classic DC movies particularly Michael Keaton's
Batman movies as well as the Snyder Versa movies
just in general I've got a whole bunch of other
videos planned for the movie and a bunch of
other big stuff coming up like the Blue Beetle
movie is supposed to be part of James Gunn's
new DC chapter one that movie will come later
this year they just released a new trailer
for us so of course I'll post that video as
quickly as possible this week once you do have a
chance to see the movie just post your reactions
in the comments below and let me know what you
want them to do with the flash character going
forward because we did just get Spider-Man across
the spider-verse though I will say I didn't like
it quite as much as I like Spider-Man across the
spider verse but it was pretty solid speaking of
which everybody click here for my full Spider-Man
across the spider-verse Easter eggs video they're
a billion Easter eggs it's a little more packed
with stuff than The Flash movie was but The Flash
movie is also packed with a lot of stuff and
click here for all my other Flash Movie videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!